your Netflix is special when you go to
Netflix calm or pull up the Netflix app
on your phone you're not just looking at
the same Netflix as everyone else you're
looking at a special version of Netflix
just for you
almost everyone watching this will
already know that Netflix customizes
what shows and movies it displays based
on your viewing habits Netflix has said
that they know if they don't get most
people watching something within 90
seconds they'll lose interest and move
on to something else so when you look at
this page you're looking at a complex
system of multiple ai's working together
to help you find something you want to
watch as quickly as possible if you're
like me you might have noticed recently
that there are multiple versions of
artwork for a lot of shows and movies I
found this interesting but didn't think
much of it thinking that possibly they
just rotated through various images to
make the library of available shows and
movies look fresh and interesting the
Netflix streaming homepage used to look
something like this artwork for videos
was adapted from or very similar to the
poster or DVD cover artwork what's
designed to grab your attention on a
large poster or DVD case isn't usually
the best for a small thumbnail on a
website
Netflix realized this at has been making
custom artwork for shows and movies for
a couple years now but it's not enough
for them to just customize things for
the site in December 2017 Netflix
released an article detailing the way
they use machine learning to personalize
the images displayed for each user the
idea is simple display the image that
will show users what aspect of a piece
of media they'll be most interested in
here's one of the examples they use if
you watch a lot of Booma Thurman movies
then you'll probably get this artwork
for pulp fiction never watch anything
with uma in it but have watched
everything with John Travolta that
Netflix has to offer and you'll probably
get this version of the artwork it can
also be customized based on genre prefer
romance movies you'll probably get this
artwork for Good Will Hunting more into
comedies than romance
you'll probably get this artwork instead
there are a lot of different versions of
each image and you might see certain
ones depending on what country you're
from if you're using Netflix on your
phone computer or TV generally the type
of design aesthetics you like and many
other factors in practice it's not as
simple as just showing the image that's
most likely to get you to click there
are a lot of things that complicate the
selection process to predict what you'll
prefer Netflix is tracking everything
you do on the site what you click on
what you watch how long you watch it and
the key thing they're looking for is
called a quality engagement Netflix
wants you to find something you actually
want to watch so if you click on
something and then stop watching it that
defeats the purpose because of this they
try to avoid clickbait images that
misrepresent the piece of media Netflix
also has to take into consideration the
look of the page as a whole a certain
image might stand out just because it's
different from the rest of the artwork
on the page for example images with
large emotional faces generally get the
most clicks but if all the artwork is of
a large emotional face an image might
stand out and get a click just because
it's different you can learn a lot about
what Netflix thinks you like by looking
at your homepage glancing over mine and
my wife's it's clear we like to watch a
lot of crime dramas documentaries and
historical fiction look at one of my
brother's home pages and you'll see a
lot of action-adventure animation and
fantasy content here's my sister's page
where the difference of color scheme is
immediately obvious each of these have a
unique look and feel and it's not just
the images that Netflix is customizing
each row is selected and arranged by
algorithm and the contents of each row
are chosen to help you find content
you're interested in watching even the
number of rows shown is personalized
based on your viewing habits Netflix is
trying to balance showing you new things
and changing the layout so that it's
fresh was staying consistent enough that
you can find something you saw before
there are thousands of variables and
infinite combinations but the result is
a unique page for each user
Netflix thinks of itself not as having
one product by having over a hundred
million products one for each customer
an interesting rule of thumb is that
stuff found on the top left corner of
the page is what Netflix thinks you're
most likely to watch and the stuff found
in the bottom right corner is what
Netflix thinks you're least likely to
watch this personalization is everywhere
search results are personalized think
what shows up in the training now Row is
the same for everyone
nope those are training items chosen
just for you these three screenshots
were taken from different profiles on
the same day at the
they even show you the continue watching
row based on whether or not they think
you're in the middle of binging
something or in the mood for something
new I wanted to conduct an experiment to
see how easily I could influence the
system
I started up a fresh profile and decided
to only click on the artwork that didn't
have people or faces this proved to be
difficult as almost all the artwork
initially contained a person but if I
kept choosing only images without people
with that change it's easy to imagine a
future where almost every element of a
service is personalized for you right
down to the interface design where the
copy used to describe something and this
might be a great thing for the most part
we all love it when something we use
fits how we use it but it's easy to
imagine a future where this could go
wrong if Netflix bases their
personalization on certain assumptions
like if you spend more time watching
Netflix you're less likely to cancel
your subscription then there could be
some unintended results what if the
personalization gets so good that you
start watching too much Netflix and in
an effort to be more productive you
cancel your subscription to remove the
temptation you can see things like this
already happening with Facebook Facebook
has gotten very good at showing you
things and giving you the notifications
that keep you coming back to Facebook
but the more time people spend on
Facebook the more many people realize
that they don't want to be spending a
lot of time on Facebook and it's often
easier to just leave altogether than it
is to try to cut back hopefully
companies and personalization AIS will
realize this and they'll start to
customize things so that you watch
enough but not too much even if they're
motivated purely by profit hopefully
Netflix will realize that the best
Netflix user isn't the one who watches
Netflix for 6 hours a day but the one
that has a healthy active lifestyle
because maybe not watching Netflix so
much could add years to your lifespan
effectively allowing you to subscribe to
Netflix for longer back to my experiment
you can see that after just a few days
Netflix began showing me many more
images without people or faces the
algorithm responded quickly to my fake
preferences even going against what
works for the majority of users it's
good for us to be aware of how things
are being personalized and customized
around us it's fairly innocent when it's
just Netflix helping you find a show
you'll like
what happens when our news is
personalized for what we like or our
search results I can already imagine a
black mirror episode where Wikipedia is
personalized to contain only the facts
that you find interesting don't get me
wrong
I love what Netflix is doing there's
data that their goal is to make us so
that you can start up Netflix and it
automatically starts playing the thing
you want to watch and if they accomplish
that that would be very cool it's why
their app feels lightyears ahead of most
of the other streaming video apps out
there but we can't be naive to what's
going on behind the scenes and how it
might be affecting us I'd like to thank
my patreon supporters for helping make
this channel possible I've recently
started up a patreon exclusive podcast
where I talk about upcoming videos
review movies and TV I've been watching
and answer questions head over to
patreon.com slash Thomas flight to hear
it for yourself or to explore the other
patreon rewards I have available as
always thanks for watching